what is going on everybody welcome to
the fourth finance with Python using
quanto peon and zipline tutorial in this
tutorial we're gonna be talking about
the inclusion of fundamental data so
fundamental data is fundamentally
different than what most people are
doing a sort of algorithmic trading on
for the most part so most people when
they do algorithmic trading they're
mainly using quant data so they're
looking in terms and actually I would
even say automated trading I would say
most hint most traders trade on really
simple stuff like moving average cross
overs or the moving average Convergence
divergence the MACD the RSI is pretty
popular these kinds of things but these
things are almost inherently biased
right out of the gate because they're
derived from historical prices and
that's the whole point the idea is that
well we can use historical patterns to
protect future patterns statistically we
know that is a fallacy but people do it
in trading and actually it can be a
somewhat decent strategy with trading I
suppose you can have success but it's
it's just inherently flawed especially
if that's all you're using is these
quanta do it and people do make a lot of
money but then you have fundamental
information so so quant is basically all
on it based in patterns and in stock
price only it doesn't take into account
anything to do with the actual company
itself whereas if you use fundamental
data what fundamental data is is it's
basically its values that pertain
directly to the company and what really
should be used in the valuation of a
company so these are things like you
know price-to-book ratio or price to
earnings these types of things are you
know the current price of the company as
compared to its assets and things like
this that actually matter or historical
growth and this kind of stuff in the
actual company rather than just purely
the stock price historically though
getting your hands on fundamental data
and a programming fashion is kind of
difficult but it can be done and if you
have been following along on my channel
when we
did the scikit-learn tutorial series we
used fundamental data there and we
trained a classifier based on only using
fundamental data to classify companies
as either buy or sell and that actually
turned out to be really successful and
you'd probably be one of the few people
that's actually using a program to use
fundamental data and that's part of the
idea is how to get an edge so you've got
to be doing something else that the
majority people aren't actually doing so
anyways with quanto peon we can
incorporate fundamental data they use a
company called Morningstar and you can
query basically their database of
fundamental information and they have a
ton of metrics so just to reference that
really quick this is the quanto peon API
so you can go or I mean other
documentation so you can go to quanto
ping comm then go to help and then help
an API Docs and what we're looking for
is fundamental data so that's right here
so we'll click on that and here you go
you've got all this stuff it's got data
on over 8,000 companies and over 670
metrics per company a lot of the metrics
I've never even heard of and I'm not
really sure what the value is but that's
a lot of metrics and we could actually
later on incorporate machine learning on
those metrics if you wanted s K learn is
actually a part of quant opium so
anyways you could click on here for the
fundamentals reference page and this has
basically all of the fundamentals you
can use you can see this scroll bar its
massive I mean just tons and stuff that
we can reference so the easiest way to
figure it out at least so that I've I've
found thus far is generally a reference
fundamentals then you'll do like these
titles are like the dot and they do
asset classification then dot this I'm
just saying that because for some reason
they I don't know the documentation here
is kind of iffy if y'all are watching
again quanto peon
whenever I'm typing it in they've got
like I forget what it's called so you
know autocomplete basically and a lot of
times it doesn't pick up stuff even
though it exists like you can you it it
won't pick it up and I'll show you guys
that as we go through it but anyway just
want to show it to you guys so if you're
looking for let's say you want to find
like price - let's do price underscore -
book now
let's go book see if we can find like
the book I'm hoping to find just because
I know they have priced a book but it's
really hard and this is a great example
of how you can actually find find what
you're looking for so tangible book
value I really thought that I could do
price book
let's try Wow what have I done
price book and then let's do ratio maybe
no how about PBR no oh here we go PB
ratio okay so anyway it exists it's just
like really difficult to find what
you're looking for and since they have
as many metrics as they do figuring or
finding what you want it's just a little
impractical to like I don't know read
through the entire documentation of all
the metrics so anyways I wish they would
improve that but anyway this is what
we've got
so coming over to our script now let's
actually make this happen so again
initialize this is what runs once on the
scripts loading although if you do trade
live initializes run once a day so keep
that in mind just so you know so this
will be we'll start with context dot
limit and we're going to say the limit
is equal to ten then what we're going to
do is we're going to have a new method
that we haven't really covered yet and
that's going to be before trading start
so this method is exactly what it sounds
like before the day of trading begins
this method will be run and we're going
to use this to update what's called our
universe and our universe is the stocks
that we're willing to trade so initially
when we say context stocks and
initialize and we say the stocks that
we're willing to trade is just just
Apple let's say that's our universe our
entire stock universes Apple we can pick
a lot of stocks and that would be our
universe the maximum amount of stocks
you can have with quanto peein is 255 so
moving right along we're going to have
our define before underscore trading
underscore starts and we pass context
through it now the way that contexts are
I mean the the fundamentals is going to
work as it uses SQ alchemy
so you can run an SQ alchemy query and
it will query their database with that
so for example what we could say is we
can make a new we could say context dot
fundamentals so we're just writing
something here equals and then we use
get underscore and there's even our
choice fundamentals so get fundamentals
and you'll notice that when I clicked
that it just like filled it in for me
like it just created the query for me
thanks that is great I love that so here
you can see basically are your options
you've got a query so basic SQL can be
query that we can write a filter you can
filter down everything order by if you
want to order it you know you say you
want to order by market cap you can
order by market cap or something like
that and then limit right now is set to
a hundred we'll leave one hundred that's
totally fine or actually let's use our
context limit so let's copy that paste
and again the maximum you can even do is
255 at least that's the amount of stocks
in your universe that's possible so the
most you can put there is 255 so let's
say we want a query and let's use pb
ratio for example okay so this will be
our query and we're going to say we want
to query fundamentals dot and then
valuation underscore ratios it did not
find that for me and then good that's
what I want
oops fundamentals dot valuation
underscore ratios see it didn't find it
so 10 let me use it very annoying anyway
then dot and then again it's not finding
PB ratio why it's not finding that I
really don't know but we can come over
to quanto peon help and again here we
see PB ratio so let's find the heading
that PB ratio is under there you go the
heading is valuation ratios so that's
how I knew it was valuation understand
underscore ratios I just knew that
because how it's documented here again
I really wish they would document it
some other way but that's what was what
we got right now so that's ok so
fundamentals of valuation so that's
going to give us the price to book ratio
for everything and heck let's go ahead
and get the p/e ratios to
is price to earnings so fundamentals Val
and again it's not driving me nuts so
you can see here okay so you've got
valuation ratios I'm just going to try
to see if I can find it so what if we
did I just want to see if I can get p/e
ratio no how about price to know about
again p/e
no so again I'm not really sure why they
have it the way they do
but anyway ratios dot PE underscore
ratio I'm doing something obviously
wrong I'd love to know why it's acting
like that to me but it doesn't make
sense to me anyway
fundamentals so here we're querying for
the price to book ratio and then the
price to earnings ratio so we're getting
that information on every company so we
need to start filtering so what if we
want to filter based on price to
earnings generally what people want is a
price to earnings around twelve anything
higher than twelve is generally a little
overpriced maybe under twelve is maybe a
little under priced but again it's going
to vary significantly based on mainly
growth though so if if the company is
projected to grow significantly in the
next few years
price to earnings might actually be
quite high okay so I think what we'll do
is we'll cut the video here and then
we'll continue in the next one with the
filter and the order by limit and then
we'll probably be able to actually run
this an actually back test or script
here so that's what we'll be doing the
next tutorial so stay tuned for that and
thanks for watching